So, da bin ich.
Heute müssen wir endlich die Skillliste fertig machen, dass ich die in den nächsten paar
Tagen schicken kann.
Lebenslauf habe ich mir heute schon mehr oder weniger außen den Fingern gesaugt, da muss
ich bloß jetzt nochmal die ganzen Termine gucken, ob das auch alles so stimmt, wie ich
es in Erinnerung habe.
Ich brauche wieder High-IQ-Ideen von euch, was ich da reinschreiben kann.
Ihr wisst besser als ich, was ich alles schon gemacht habe, gerade im Stream.
Ups, warum habe ich jetzt Stadia aufgemacht?
Musik kann sich wieder nicht entscheiden, ob es laut oder leise sein will.
Ah, so geht das.
Hier gibt es Skills.
Ja, hast du schon was mit CICD?
Ich glaube schon.
Wartet mal, ich mache das mal kurz auf.
Skills.
Ja, also es ist alles sehr unorganisiert noch.
Oh, Chain Law, seit heute oder was?
Zedge.
Was hältst du vom Studiengang Wirtschaftsinformatik?
Naja, warum nicht?
Also, was halte ich davon?
Kann man machen.
Man weiß jetzt nicht, was ich groß dazu sagen soll, ehrlich gesagt.
Die meisten Leute, die ich kenne, die Wirtschaftsinformatik studiert haben, haben das hauptsächlich
deswegen studiert, weil sie keinen Bock hatten auf das volle Mathe-Programm vom normalen
Informatikstudium und nicht so sehr, weil sie Wirtschaft so geil fanden.
Ich weiß ja nicht, wie es bei dir aussieht.
Warum du das studieren willst?
Warum willst du es denn studieren?
Leute, was meint ihr?
Neuer Rechner, CPU, 7950 AMD oder 13900K Intel?
Leistungstechnisch müsste es eigentlich Intel sein.
Aber Intel hat, glaube ich, auch echt krassen, zumindest in der Spitze krassen Stromverbrauch.
Wolltest du nicht dein Skill-Sheet weiterwarnen?
Doch.
Doch, doch.
Waren wir heute fertig.
Bisschen Markdown.
Komm, wir machen mal Markdown-Überschrift hier.
Skillorts, alles klar, ja, das schreibe ich da so drüber.
13900, ja, ich tendiere auch dazu, tendiere da auch dazu.
Chatting, ich habe ein neues Emote geadded, Leute, ich glaube, das haben wir schon eine
Weile drinnen.
Oh, Moment, wo sind die Emotes hin?
FFZ?
FFZ kaputt?
Oder was?
Was ist hier los?
Leute, FFZ ist broken.
Hat sich FFZ neu installiert oder was?
Ich blick da mittlerweile nicht mehr durch.
Dark Mode will ich haben.
Gibt es das nicht mehr?
Plugin?
Wo gibt es denn hier die Plugins noch mal drinnen?
Wo ist denn da Kram?
Control Center?
Ach, erinnert uns, hier.
Ja gut, das bringt nix, weil...
Emotes?
Hat sich das irgendwie resetten oder was?
Was ist denn das hier schon wieder?
Ich glaube, jetzt geht es wieder, oder?
Was auch immer, der für Schmerzen hat.
Ja, und ich weiß auch nicht, warum das hier nicht im Dark Mode ist, aber okay, man.
Vielleicht ist es...
Hatte ich nicht eigentlich auch Timestamps?
Nee, hier hatte ich keine Timestamps, die hatte ich nur bei mir auf dem anderen Bildschirm.
A Kriege.
Du hast letzte Woche deinen bisherigen Arbeitgeber gequittet.
Was waren deine Gründe, warum du keinen Bock mehr hattest?
Warte, ich hatte Timestamps, okay.
Weiß nicht, warum sich das resetten hat.
Trennilien, ja, das hatten wir auch, oder?
Hatte ich das nicht auch, hatte ich nicht auch unterschiedliche?
Ich kann doch einfach gucken, wie mein Chat letzten Stream ausgeschaut hat.
Was hast du noch nicht mitbekommen?
Naja, das ist schon so gemein, wie es im Titel steht.
Also wenn sich bei uns nicht großartig was ändert, bin ich Ende des Jahres weg.
So, zeige ich mal her, wie sah das letzte Stream aus?
Gestern.
Hier, so sah der Chat gestern noch aus, okay.
Okay, nur Timestamps hatte ich noch, alles klar.
Ja, anscheinend.
Du warst eine Ein-Mann-IT-Abteilung, sozusagen.
Naja, du kannst es ja auch nicht groß mitbekommen, ich erzähle das ja nicht wahnsinnig, ich zähle
das ja nicht großartig rum.
Also ich habe gerade ein Angebot, was ich echt nicht schlecht finde, das werde ich mir
jetzt mal ein bisschen näher angucken, und wenn man sich da einig wird, was Teilzeit
angeht und was Gehalt angeht, ich meine, das ist quasi 99% Remote, es gibt irgendwie
zwei Events im Jahr, wo man hin muss, ja, soll mir recht sein.
Aber das in Kombination ist mir einfach viel lieber als unser Boomer-Management, was von
Homeoffice nichts hält.
Kommt zu uns, nee, ihr wart die.NET-Entwickler, nee, da hatte ich keinen Bock drauf, ich so
sehr ich sie scharf mag, hauptberuflicher.NET-Entwickler, habe ich keinen Bock.
Wenn du weg bist, ist Platz für drei Consultants, nee, das ist ja gerade das Problem, kosten
ja mehr Geld.
So sieht es aus, sehe ich genauso, das muss drin stehen.
Wie gesagt, gegen eins, zwei, drei Sachen mal Events im Jahr, soll mir recht sein, ja,
so weit weg ist es auch nicht.
Aber gerade nach dem Laden, wo ich jetzt bin, die sich ja auch so sehr davor drücken mit
Homeoffice, ich will das auf jeden Fall vertraglich geregelt haben, ja, ja, ja, ist halt bei uns
so.
Gut, ich weiß ja nicht, wie es bei dir ausschaut, ist ein bisschen was anderes, aber trotzdem,
die sind irgendwie nicht so ganz, was ich dann bin, tja, ich weiß nur, dass ich dann endlich
Senior im Titel hab, ich hab's, ich weiß es gar nicht genau, wie die Stelle jetzt konkret
hieß, weil ich bewerbe mich nicht explizit auf was, was jetzt, was schon ausgeschrieben
ist, Ex-Kollege hat mich angerufen, letztens hat gemeint, Max willst nicht bei uns anfangen,
aber ich hab, er hat mir auch gesagt, wie es genau heißt, ich weiß nur noch, dass Senior
im Titel ist, nicht, dass ich da großartig drauf Wert legen würde, aber ich mein, hey,
ich mach den Kram jetzt quasi 15 Jahre lang, da kann man, kann man auch Senior im Titel
haben und alt genug, dafür bin ich ja mittlerweile auch.
Unsere Consultants haben mich heute schon wieder wahnsinnig gemacht, ich hab ja heute nur E-Mails
gelesen.
Daily Scrum, Leute, 20 Uhr steht Daily Scrum an, jeder eine Minute, was er heute vor hat
zu machen, was wollte ich jetzt sagen, man könnte das langsam in Senior in Boomer ändern,
denn das müssten aber die an der Position entscheiden, die es betrifft, das werden sie
nicht machen, heute hat mir einer auf Twitter geschrieben, dass in meinem Bild Chemtrails
oder Chemtrails zu sehen waren, guck mal, ich hoffe ja, ich hoffe ja ein bisschen hier,
ich hoffe ja ein bisschen ertreut nur, guck mal, hab ich heute gepostet, da meinte einer,
da meinte einer jetzt in den Kommentaren drauf, hier siehst du Chemtrails, warte mal, irgendwo
hier, schön zu sehen, dass es auch dort schon verteilt wird, Chemtrails und danach kam noch
eine Antwort an, ich glaube er meint es halt irgendwie ernst, ich hoffe ja, ich hoffe ja,
dass es getrollt ist, ja, dachte Chemtrails und so ist es komplett outdated Verschwörungstheorie,
das nutzt keiner mehr, ich dachte es ist so ein bisschen was wie Hohlerde, Hohlerde ist
auch total out, flache Erde, flache Erde ist schon angesagt aktuell, was Verschwörung
angeht, aber Hohlerde ist nicht mehr so das, und ich weiß auch nicht, wie es mit den Nazis
auf der Rückseite des Mondes und so aussieht, das ist auch nicht mehr so angesagt an Verschwörungstheorie
glaube ich, ich hab letztens wieder ein Video geguckt, ich guck ja manchmal solche Flat
Earth Fail Compilations und sowas, da hat letztens wieder einer erzählt, die Dark Side
of the Moon, also die uns abgewandte Mondseite, da wäre es ja immer dunkel, hab ich mir auch
gedacht, was erzählt der Typ, da ist nicht immer dunkel, da scheint auch die Sonne drauf,
manchmal, wir sehen es bloß nicht, ja die haben sogar schon glaube ich vor 40 Jahren
oder so mal da ne Sonde hingeschrieben, ne nicht Dark Side, das war es Far Side, ja
haben es zumindest nicht, Dark Side hab ich jetzt zusammen gewurschtelt, aber da wär es
ergeblich immer dunkel, im Schwachsinn da ist es nicht immer dunkel, also, hat er Blutssinn,
ja, alles Fake, ja und nachts ist es kälter als draußen, das wissen wir ja alle, ach
Dark Side hieß der Transformers Ding, jaja, zumindest haben sie erzählt, dass es dort
ja angeblich immer dunkel wäre und niemand weiß was dort passiert und naja, wenn man
sich Sondenaufnahmen oder Probenaufnahmen anguckt, da ist halt gar nix, tja, so, so
sollen wir mal, sollen wir mal anfangen, Monkees, Zeit, ansonsten schwätze ich wieder
zwei Stunden mit euch und dann gehe ich off, so, hier sind wir stehen geblieben das letzte
Mal, ungeordnet, random Zeug, was äh dem Chet und mir so eingefallen ist, wir müssen
das noch ein bisschen ordnen, ich weiß nicht ob ich da wirklich alles reinschreiben soll,
weil es schon ganz schön, ganz schön viel, ganz schön viel Kram, ja, Knacken im Mikro
nur bei mir, du, du hast doch letztes Mal, du hast doch letztes Mal schon was vom Knacken
im Mikrofon erzählt, Mikrofon Knacktest, was ist Knackt bei dir auch?
Wait a minute, Mikrofon Knacktest, was ist Knackt bei dir auch?
Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment,
Moment, vorhin hat es geknackt, vielleicht so, weil ich hier ans Mikrofon gekommen bin,
oder wenn ich mit dem Bart irgendwie ans Mikrofon komme oder so, ja, sagt mir mal wenn es wieder
geknackt hat, sagt mir mal wenn es wieder geknackt hat, dann gucken wir, schauen wir
mal, ja, jetzt, jetzt habe ich zum Beispiel das Mikrofon gerade bewegt, hat man das gehört?
So, hört man das wenn ich das so bewege?
Ne, eigentlich nicht, ja, ja, das wird es wahrscheinlich gewesen sein, Knacken mit leichten
Aussatzern, okay, vielleicht waren das ein paar Frame Drops, naja, gucken wir mal, Keg-Wade,
gut, macht eigentlich den Lautstärker, Teams da wieder dran rumgedockt hat, achja, was ich
sagen wollte, mich haben heute wieder unsere Consultants wieder fertig gemacht, der Consultant
hat einen Change gemacht, eingecheckt, Infrastructure as Code, wurde ausgerollt, ging nicht, okay,
ja, ja, ja, wir müssen das noch ein bisschen ordnen, ich weiß nicht ob ich da wirklich
alles reinschreiben soll, weil es schon ganz schön viel, ganz schön viel Kram, ja, ja,
das hat sich tatsächlich kaputt angehört, das könnte, das könnte aber tatsächlich,
beim Upload Pack-A-Loss oder irgendwas gewesen sein, ja, schon wieder, ah, ich weiß woran
es liegt, ich weiß woran es liegt, ich weiß woran es liegt, ich weiß, also jetzt ist wieder
gut, ne, jetzt ist wieder gut, oder, aber jetzt, weil jetzt höre ich es ja auch nicht
mehr, ah, ah, was ist das, okay, was ist das, Moment Leute, ich entwirme mal mein Kabel,
vielleicht bringt das was, so, schauen wir mal, Test, Test, Test, so, schauen wir mal,
Test, Test, Test. Okay, wenn ich das jetzt bewege, wenn ich das bewege, fängt es dann
wieder an zu knacken, oder wie ist das? Okay, wenn ich das jetzt bewege, wenn ich das bewege,
fängt es dann wieder an zu knacken, oder wie ist das? Schein am Kabel, nein, das hat
nicht angefangen zu knacken, ich habe es doch jetzt selbst gehört, das hat jetzt ein bisschen
gerieben am Mikrofon, aber das war es, also jetzt ist nichts mehr, ne, jetzt ist nichts
mehr, es ist wirklich, es ist wirklich merkwürdig, keine Ahnung was das ist, jaja, ist klar,
jetzt ist Echo, alles klar, jebaited, was das ist, jaja, ist klar, jetzt ist Echo, alles
klar, jeba-, was das ist, okay, das ist, das ist, das war das Kabel, aus irgendwelchen
Gründen, keine Ahnung, was das Kabel für Schmerzen hat, ich weiß nicht, IP Adresse,
ja, so stehe ich gleich raus, guck, jetzt bin ich wieder ins Mikrofon gekommen, aber
das ist nicht das Problem, ich habe es eben auch gehört, so, also weiter geht's, also
ich habe die ganze Sache hier relativ ungeordnet hingeschrieben, wir müssen jetzt mal überlegen,
also, lass mal kurz in mich gehen, also, Linux, 15 Jahre Linux-Erfahrung, Red Hat, CentOS,
Ubuntu, Debian, Arch-Spidey-Way, soll ich das haben, das hat halt Shed letztens geschrieben,
ich schreibe nicht Arch-Spidey-Way rein, ich schreibe es einfach nur so, ich kann da nicht
Arch-Spidey-Way reinschreiben, im Summer, Web-Server, Reverse-Box, Nginx, Kali, das
kann ich wahrscheinlich dann weglassen, ok, ich muss mir irgendwie husten, so, die ganze
DevOps-Geschichte, ok, wenn euch da noch was einfällt, sagt Puppet, Puppet habe ich tatsächlich
auch noch ein bisschen Ahnung, fuck, warum muss ich jetzt so bloßen, ok, Monitoring,
Prometheus, Kafana Nagios, Influx DB, alles klar, ok, Cloud, Cloudgedöns, Cloudflare,
Cloudflare habe ich tatsächlich schon ein paar Sachen mitgemacht, Serverless Azure Functions,
ja, mal ein bisschen Zeug hin, ok, jetzt machen wir den, so, hier schreiben wir natürlich
CI, CD noch rein, du wolltest die Linux-Tools noch zusammenfassen, ok, ne, Datenbank habe
ich keine Ahnung von, ja, habe ich ja schon sowas, das haben wir, so, das haben wir schon,
da wollte einer jetzt hier plus plus schreiben, ok, schreiben wir, wie nennt man das, Development
oder Softwareentwicklung oder irgendwie sowas, Hashtag Progers, so, da muss ich jetzt mal
die ganzen Kempel hinschreiben, also was habe ich denn, was habe ich denn Ahnung von,
vielleicht sollte ich hier oben noch, hier muss noch hin, Loadbalancing, Hochverfügbarkeit,
Software Engineering, coolen Sachen, Cobol, Cobol musste auf jeden Fall hin, ja, das kann
ich, das kann ich von unten mir dann rauskopieren, IoT wollten wir noch machen, ok, ich lösche
die Sachen mal raus, die ich schon oben stehen habe, KVM muss da nicht, muss da KVM rein,
KVM können wir ruhiger reinschreiben, Containerisierung, ist Containerisierung ein Wort, schreibt man
das so, Containerisierung tatsächlich, mal die interessanten Sachen eben ein bisschen
oben hin, ok, also Serverless, schreibe ich, das schreibe ich einfach dabei, passt das
sonst, passt das sonst ganz gut hin, so IoT können wir noch machen, I'm not, kann ich
nicht genau sagen wie die Stelle heißt, weil mich hat ein ehemaliger Kollege angerufen
hat gemeint, Max willst du nicht bei uns anfangen und ich habe mit ihm telefoniert und hat mir
auch gesagt wie das heißt, ich glaube es war irgendwas, entweder Senior, was war es denn,
es war nicht Senior DevOps Engineer, es war auch nicht Senior Admin, es war Senior Engineer
Development Infrastruktur oder sowas, Senior Engineer Development Infrastructure, irgendwie
sowas, ich krieg's aus dem Kopf nicht genau an, was ist das denn, Chat ihr verarscht mich
doch jetzt oder, was ist das denn, wie jetzt, was ist da los, was soll das, ich hab mich
überhaupt nicht bewegt, wie jetzt, was ist da los, ok, ok, wir versuchen das jetzt nach
zu vollziehen, ich wackel jetzt, ich wackel jetzt hier mal am, aha jetzt hab ich was gehört,
jetzt hat es ein bisschen geknackt, jetzt bewege ich mal hier das Kabel und das Zeug, ok,
ok, ok, das ist sehr merkwürdig, ich weiß nicht was das ist, das ist sehr merkwürdig,
es liegt auch nicht an OBS, ich hab's ja eben auch in Audacity gehört, ich weiß bis heute
nicht, ob man das so ausspricht, vielleicht ist es auch Windows Bullshit und nach einem
Restart ist es weg, man weiß ja nicht, ok, IoT, da kann ich auf jeden Fall noch reinschreiben,
also da schreib ich, das weiß ich gar nicht ob ich das hinschreibe hier, das hat ja für
meinen Job überhaupt keine Relevanz so, letztendlich, ich mein, das ist eigentlich total irrelevant
dafür, ok, Software Engineering, was haben wir denn da, da kann ich den Kram von hier
unten nehmen, Serverless, Serverless schreiben wir einfach mal, nee Serverless hab ich da
oben schon stehen, Progas, so das kann weg, Object Detection, das haben wir tatsächlich
schon im Stream gemacht mit OpenCL, war das glaub damals, Protobuf, gRPC, HiIQ, Begriffe
einfach mal hier eingeschmissen, Shell Scripting, Retardsenders, ok, das hab ich alles schon,
Windows, wisst ihr was da rauskommt, wenn ich da drauf klicke, wenn mich einer was zu
Windows fragt, Open, das kommt da raus, wenn mich einer zu Windows fragt, oder eigentlich
sollte besser das da rauskommen, eigentlich bräuchten wir das, ich will nicht Kubernetes
reinschreiben, die Sache ist die, ich hab Basic Ahnung von Kubernetes, aber ich bin
jetzt niemand der irgendeinen Kubernetes Cluster aufbauen kann, ich kann da was deployen, ich
kann da was restarten, aber super krass Ahnung von Kubernetes hab ich net, ja ich lerne das
bis morgen, wenn ich abschicken muss, den Manage Kubernetes kann ich aufbauen, ich meine,
ich kann das ja durchaus mal reinschreiben, aber vielleicht soll ich lieber Kubernetes,
naja komm, komm wir schreiben K8S rein, die coolen wissen das, die Skills brauchen eigentlich
noch eher ein Skill Level, theoretisch schon, es knackt wieder, Leute ihr könnt mich jetzt
mega Chebaten, ihr könnt mich den ganzen Tag Chebaten jetzt und ich muss das nachkommen,
ok das liegt dann wirklich an der Bewegung hier, vielleicht kackt das wirklich, ja wenn
ich den, ich merke es gerade, wenn ich den Kopf, ja wenn ich den Kopf, ja das ist wenn
ich den Kopf in falsche Richtung bewege, ich glaube das das Headset gibt langsam den Geist,
aber ich meine, ohne Scheiß ich meine ich hab das Headset jetzt seit 2010 oder so, 2011,
übelst lange schon, das ist immer noch das MMX300, ja das MMX300 das finde ich das beste,
was es gibt, also wenn man es nicht total übertreiben will, natürlich kann man sich
auch und das ist wahrscheinlich insgesamt die bessere Wahl, ja auch ein Kopfhörer kaufen
mit Mikrofon, aber angenehmer ist es halt trotzdem mit dem Headset, ich könnte mir tatsächlich
mal ein neues MMX300 gönnen oder, warte mal hat es da oben auch so ein Polster wie das
hier her, du hast ja selber gebaut, naja selber gebaut wollte ich gerade sagen ist ein DT770
mit dem Mikrofon, ich hab kein Voice Meter, wie gesagt ich siehs ja hier, ich hab direkt,
wir können da direkt das Mikrofon einstellen, ansonsten ich meine ich könnte, wenn es gar
nicht hilft, ich könnte hier mal ein bisschen dran rumdrehen oben an der Verlängerung oder
so, aber ja, wir lassen es jetzt einfach mal, ok also IOT, MQTT das ist ok, das ist ziemlich
egal, also Softwareengine, da kann ich von hier unten was kopieren, Brotobuff ist doch
ein GRPC Gedöns oder, so also es kommt da irgendwie rein, Cloud, Netlify kann ich da
tatsächlich auch noch reinschreiben, exellent, exellent, was haben wir hier sonst noch, Alibaba
Cloud, so ein Blödsinn, weil ich da für den Scheiß reingeschrieben hab, ok das kann
ich, das kann ich kopieren, was ist was, Netlify, Netlify ist ein Dienst, was gerade angesagt
ist wenn du deine, ich kanns ja noch mal schreiben, Net, Netlify, so jetzt, da kannst du deine
Web Anwendung drauf deployen und nach Möglichkeiten möglichst nah an dem ausliefern der die Seite
ausmacht, die die Seite aufmacht, also hauptsächlich wird es, wurde es die ganze Zeit für statisches,
statischen Web Content, ein bisschen sowas wie Versel, ja, ja, im Prinzip ist es recht
ähnlich, ja, ok also das kann ich doch jetzt gerade mal hier übernehmen und dann müsst
ihr mir sagen, Node.js muss da auf jeden Fall nachhinein, Frontend, Frontend machen wir dann,
so, Shit++, GitHubX, haben wir alle schon, ja, IDE Editors muss ich da nicht, muss ich
da nicht reinschreiben, Tools, Tools, Tools könnte man vielleicht noch irgendwie, die
Skillbars sind sinnlos, ja die kommen auch weg, ja in Vim könnte ich jetzt D drücken
und dann einfach Punkt, Java, Kekkel, ok die Hälfte davon stimmt ja gar nicht, die Hälfte
stimmt ja davon gar nicht, also, PainsChamp muss da schon mal nicht hin, so, also Cobol
ist da auch eher der Witz, ja, können Sie mich aber fragen, so C Sharp, sagt man das
eigentlich offiziell groß oder klein, C Sharp, Ruby, Bash, Shells, Gripting, Go, die Hype
Sprachen, mal ein bisschen weiter oben, Git ist auch drauf, so, also, Chat was habe ich
denn vergessen, Blatter, also, ich habe in PowerShell schon mal was gemacht, ja, hat
ich schon mal gemacht, ja, so, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja,
ja, so, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, wire地, Allg Berry
Ja plan von was gibt es kraft ql
Vue gs. Ich view jason
homocyste
Ja
Da war wahrscheinlich kein interessieren kann man ja mal hinschreiben markt dauern
Die
Warum nicht
web assembly c++ ffm pack ne ffm pack muss ich da
Was gibt es da kommen wir kommen wir sind wir sind mal so frei
Wir schreiben einfach, wir schreiben einfach alles rein.
CSV.
Svelte, Svelte, Svelte Kit, halt man so.
Gibt es Dokumentationstools mit denen du dich auskennst?
Naja also Tools kenne ich mich ganz gut aus mit Jyra, mit Confluence, Dokuviki, ist das
Snippingtool, Bitbucket haben wir oben schon stehen.
Ich weiß gar nicht was ich da sonst noch dazu hinschreiben soll, was soll man denn bei
Tools hinschreiben?
Keine Ahnung, ich muss erst mal, ich muss erst mal den anderen Krämpel hier fertig
machen, sonst fällt mir nix mehr ein.
WebRTC haben wir Zeug gemacht.
Google Maps haben wir Zeug gemacht.
Tailwind, CSS haben wir Zeug gemacht, das fällt mir nicht mehr ein.
Postman, sehr gut, sehr gut.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, seht AWK, DD nicht rein, das habe ich hier oben aber das lasse ich
raus.
Das ist doch bescheuert, üblichen Tools, die braucht doch...
Interessiert doch keinen.
LSD, PWD, ja genau.
Die Scout, JetBrains, Netzwerk, ja stimmt, ich habe eine
CCNA 2009 oder so gemacht, ja geil, das hat die Welt, das hat die Welt gebraucht.
Rest, Soap und, oh Gott, kann ich ja ewig aufzählen.
Rust, ok, Programmiersprache, Rust, bisschen, bisschen war es schon gemacht, ja, sogar,
sogar mehr als Basics, ColdFusion, was kommt als nächstes?
Lotus Notes oder wie?
Wenn schon dann so, warte mal, haben wir nicht Stream-Projekt-Ideen, Stream-Ideen, ok, keine
Ahnung.
So, jetzt da haben wir schon drinne, Monitoring haben wir auch schon, Monitoring haben wir
schon drinne, mir fällt jetzt wenig, Grafana haben wir auch schon drinne, ich meine sollte
doch eigentlich reichen, das ist quasi hier ganze IT-Abteilung, Cloud Asher könnte man
noch aufschlüsseln in die konkreten Produkte, das ist wohl wahr, aber das können sie mich
ja dann fragen, ich meine, GraphQL habe ich auch schon drinne, das liest, wollte quasi
liest sich eh keiner durch, wir ordnen mal die Sprachen so ein bisschen, hast du sonst
keine Zertifizierung, nö, das schreibe ich da gar nicht rein, das ist mir zu doof, kann
ich jetzt hinschreiben, beste besten Soft-Skills aller Zeiten, WebAssembly haben wir schon
drinne stehen, das war einfach nur genehmt im Stream, das schreibe ich so bestimmt nicht
rein, das ist zu viel, ja ich denke auch, dass es zu viel ist, so irgendeine noch schlaue
Ideen, also wie gesagt, wir können das auch ein bisschen zusammenfassen, das ist eigentlich
viel zu viel, wie sieht denn das in Markdown aus, wenn man das rendert, ach das ist eine
TXT, das ist gar kein Markdown, heck wait, oh ok, nice, easy, gg, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok...
Ehrlich gesagt zum größten Teil ein Wrishel Studio Debugger, aber ansonsten hält es sich
Grenzen.
Profiler Tracing Tools Performance.
Tracing Tool Console Write Line.
Zählt das auch?
Print F.
Ich sag auch einfach fehlerfrei programmieren, dann braucht man keine Debugger.
Wie gesagt, um die, ähm, jetzt mach ich mal raus, weil ansonsten check ich dann noch
aus Versehen ab.
So hab ich Ahnung von Datenbanken Leute, ich hab tatsächlich, ich hab ein bisschen Ahnung
von, ähm, Postgres, Fulltext Search, SQLite, Redis hab ich tatsächlich ein bisschen Plan
so Minimal, ich kenn Redis auch nur quasi als Cash, so als Cash Key Value Store, beziehungsweise
so als, ähm, PubSub Lite und es war ne Zeit lang halt mega angesagt, ist es glaub ich
immer noch.
Elastic Search hab ich wenig Plan von, Cassandra DB hab ich auch keine Ahnung von, also ich,
das einzige, pass auf, jetzt hab ich wieder am Mikrofon bewegt, ähm, das einzige was
ich von Cassandra DB weiß, aber das reicht nicht um mich da zu qualifizieren zum draufschreiben,
dass das irgendein verteiltes Datenbank System ist, aber ich hab die elfte schon wieder vergessen
von FoxPro man, Leute mir gehts nicht darum, dass ich da irgendwas reinschreibe, das muss
schon was sein wo ich ein bisschen Plan habe, ja es steht aktuell gerade zur Diskussion
ja, ja das stimmt hab ich gesehen, also ich hab ein Angebot, mich hat jemand angerufen
und hat gesagt hier Max willst du nicht bei uns anfangen und ich hab gesagt jo, erzählt
mal und ich find das Klip hört sich echt nicht übel an, ich hab ihm gesagt ich schick
ihm mal eine Skillliste ohne Lebenslauf,.NET Developer Roadmap, mal gucken was ich davon
kann, ok, MonkaS zeigt mal her, wie gesagt ich arbeite, ich werde nicht als.NET Entwickler
arbeiten dort, also das ist nicht so, Alter wie fett ist denn das, JIT, HTTP, HTTPS, naja
gut, ah das hier ist tatsächlich gar nicht mal so blöd, wie SQLite soll man nicht lernen
oder was ist das, ach you must know, ja Prometheus, Grafana, datadoc, kenn ich aber hab ich noch
nie was mitgemacht, ist einfach teuer as fuck, hast du Kurzbeschreibungen zu Projekten,
im Zweifelsfall gebe ich denen mein GitHub Account und dann können sie sich erstmal
20 Projekte angucken mit Champ im Namen wo keiner weiß was ich gemacht hab, das soll
nämlich dann fragen was sie genau wissen wollen, das ist ja noch wie gesagt, ist nicht dass
ich da morgen anfange, ich will mir das eh auch erstmal angucken, ich hab schon gefragt
ob man mal so einen Probetag machen könnte, dass ich das mal angucken kann, die werden
rausfinden dass du Streamer bist, naja derjenige der mich angerufen hat, der weiß ja dass ich
YouTube mache und Twitch, naja das ist zu Software lastig, naja warum nicht, naja, naja
das Monarch S Projekt, ja das ist ganz toll, oh was gehts, moin Michael, 5 Spillian, kannst
du die Ordnung posten, das wäre mal eine Frage, ja
also so viel fällt mir jetzt da wirklich nicht mehr ein, ich mein es liest doch eh
kein Mensch durch, noch irgendjemand, irgendwelche schlauen Ideen, nicht was ich reinschreiben
wollte, sondern irgendwas was ich noch vergessen hab, also ich will jetzt ja nicht was reinschreiben
wovon ich keine Ahnung hab, also es ist nicht das Ziel hier möglichst viele Sachen aufzulisten
sondern Sachen mit denen ich auch schon mal mehr als einen kleinen Handschlag gemacht
hab, du würdest das einfach nur noch weiter strukturieren, das liest im Endeffekt doch
eh kein Mensch, noch mein Netzwerkrahmen vom Provider, lass mal überlegen, ja ich kann
ein bisschen, ich kann ein bisschen Cisco Command Line, ja ich weiß noch dass man Enable
machen muss am Anfang und dass man No, No SH macht um den Port hochzufahren, das krieg
ich noch aus dem Kopf hin, Conf T genau genau und dann irgendwie Backup, No Shut, No SH
macht man, ah das ist tatsächlich eine gute Idee, wenn ich hier schon die ganzen anderen
Websockets, ja generell Protokolle, bei Netzwerk, kann doch da jetzt nicht TCP, das ist doch
hängen geblieben eigentlich oder, in Bewerbung sollte man nur Sachen reinschreiben die auch
für den Job relevant sind, nachdem die mir noch gar nicht genau gesagt haben was ich
eigentlich später machen soll, weil ich nur so quasi zwischen so halb offiziell mit meinem
Exkollege telefoniert hab, kann ich das nicht so genau sagen, Lifecycle Management, das ist
ein Sixhead Begriff, das muss da rein und zwar da, Lifecycle Management Massive High IQ,
was das ist, ok wenn mich einer fragen würde was ist Lifecycle Management, danach die Motto
sie haben Lifecycle Management reingeschrieben, was verstehen sie unter Lifecycle Management,
da würde ich sinngemäß sowas sagen wie ja es geht im Prinzip darum System quasi von
der Erstellung, von der wie nennt man das heutzutage, von der Professionierung bis zum
Abbau was sie in Übersicht zu haben, ansonsten keine Ahnung ob das stimmt, ich glaube schon,
also auf deutsch ist das sowas wie System Lebenszyklus oder sowas, Updates für Softwares
programmiert, ich wüsste nicht wie man das schreiben soll, keine Ahnung, Patch Management
Massive Idee, das schreiben wir nicht bei DevOps rein, das schreiben wir hier oben mit rein,
Deckdose Flaschen, null, warum nicht, Release, ja das stimmt das mache ich ja aktuell ja
gerade sogar, Release Management, Keksteam beste, ja ich finde auch die sollten sich
mal neue Bezeichnung überlegen, ah Lifecycle Management, so ich glaube das erschlägt erst,
das lasse ich raus, 123 Zeilen, die ersten 3 Management sind richtig geschrieben, ich
kann dieses Wort nicht richtig schreiben, Chat, Twitch Chat, vor allem ja ehrlich gesagt
vor allem Workstation kann ich noch einschreiben, aber Tools, ja Tools, ja ja, mit Vagrant
habe ich auch schon mal was gemacht, das ist eher DevOps Kram, ne Mail habe ich keine Ahnung,
GitOps, auch so ein geiles, so ein geiles, so ein geiler Begriff irgendwie, ja gut Virtualisierung
kann ich da tatsächlich, anstatt KVM schreibe ich, Virtualisierung, GitOps, da soll ich
aber zumindest, wie gesagt ich will eigentlich nur Sachen reinschreiben wo ich auch direkt
aus bestehgreif was zu sagen könnte, GitOps, ah ok, ich verstehe, das ist quasi DevOps
beziehungsweise CI, CD wenn man Git verwendet, so nach dem Motto, Comet kommt rein, Pulle
Request wird genehmigt, Deployment läuft los und sowas in der Richtung, ja, naja, 5
Minuten da, ok, das hört ja gar nicht mehr auf, so kam hier noch irgendwas, kam hier
noch irgendwas im Chat, schon das er schief durchgescrollt, ja, auf Stream, ich habe bestimmt
total viel Zeug noch vergessen, fällt das nicht unter DevOps, doch die Kategorien sind
eh, sag mal mal, Variabel, ja, schreibe es einfach doppelt rein, null, merkt schon keiner,
was meinst du mit Linux Lifecycle Management, ich meine dafür geiles Management-Busword,
also was sagt denn Wikipedia dazu, wie gesagt was ich da drunter verstehe, habe ich euch
schon gesagt, mal gucken was Wikipedia, Produktlebenszyklus, was sagt denn Wikipedia dazu, Produktlebenszyklus
Management, PLM, ah ja, ja das ist dann aber weniger Linux, das ist weniger Linux, ist
tatsächlich eher sowas hier, wollen wir das nicht alles in eine Zeile machen, wie sieht
es mit ITIL aus, ich habe keine ITIL Zertifizierung, ich habe weder eine safe noch ITIL noch lean
noch haste nicht gesehen, Zertifizierung, ja, will ich aber nicht hinschreiben, Bench,
ja tatsächlich, aber weiß nicht wo ich das dazu hinschreiben soll, nein Active Directory
habe ich keine, mach TOGAF, was zum Teufel ist TOGAF, die TOGAF, alter wie viel scheiß
ist da gebt man, TOGAF, Open Group Architecture Framework, Richtung AI habe ich keine Ahnung
von, ne ich schreibe alles das was ich schonmal gemacht habe, wo ich zumindest schonmal mehr
gemacht habe, als einfach nur 2 Zeilen zugelesen, den ISO 9001 hätte ich noch zu bieten, ne
habe ich keine Ahnung von, schreibe Quantencomputer hin, alles klar, Blockchain Maschine, Quatsch
Leute, ist doch blöd, ich will ja nicht diese random Buzzwords hinschreiben, UML Diagramme,
View ins Welt habe ich schon hingeschrieben, UTF-8, ey die Codings UTF-8, boah das ist
irgendeine MySQL Geschichte, ja, Docker ist selbstverständlich, ist Docker dabei, Docker
muss da relativ weit oben hin, Docker Hub, GHCR,
gute Idee, gute Idee, ne, das wird der HR Typ bestimmt nicht fragen, weil der HR Typ
von sowas keine Ahnung hat, aber das ist tatsächlich, ist auf jeden Fall nicht verkehrt,
ja, gezwungenermaßen aber nicht, dass ich davon Ahnung hätte, noch Veed können wir
noch hinschreiben, ja, Portena mag ich nicht, ey ich glaube jetzt haben wir es, Traffic
Kammer schon drinnen, haben wir es schon drinnen, wir sind nicht, wir sind nicht bei 1996, ja,
das ist die Red Hat Docker Alternative, die quasi ohne Route-Rechte funktioniert, boah
das ist, das glaube ich so der Haupt Selling Point, achso, ja tatsächlich, damit kenne
ich mich aus, ja, Raid, wo schreiben wir das hin, wo schreiben wir denn, Raid, Raid können
wir noch zu Linux schreiben oder, Raid, was ist das Besondere an Red Hat, wie, du meinst
an Red Hat, an Red Hat Linux, ja gut es ist halt ein eigener Distributionszweig, einer
der professionellen Support liefert und im Enterprise Business Sektor recht angesagt
ist, aber es gibt auch kostenlose Nachbauten, auch wenn CentOS nicht mehr gibt, aber es
gibt jetzt Rocky Linux und Alma Linux, die ich aber noch nie verwendet habe, äh, Disk
End, das muss ich doch nachher hinschreibe, also was ist denn die Red Fish API, Red Fish
API, aha, was es nicht alles gibt, habe ich noch nie, habe ich noch nie gehört, weil
das nicht Linux ist, ja was ist das, ich habe keine Ahnung, Tools, meinst du die interessieren
sich auch für deine KD, bestimmt, vielleicht sollte ich hinschreiben, dazu bräuchte das
Spiel ja erstmal Stats, bei der KD kann ich dir nicht sagen, das Game hat ja keine Stats,
Server Administration, ja gut, das sollte eigentlich, ähm, sollen wir Linux Erfahrung und Administration
irgendwie hinschreiben, Linux Erfahrung, wollen wir das so hinschreiben, Expanter
Moab World Record Holder, ohja unbedingt, Apache Meso, benutzt das überhaupt noch jemand, Ansible
steht auch schon drin, Kafka habe ich zu wenig Plan, was ist das hier, das Scalable
Platforms Management Forum, die haben auch einen geilen Namen, Red, Red Fish API, haben
iTracks Red Fish oder was, habe ich noch nie gehört Leute, haben wir wieder was gelernt,
tatsächlich interessant, wusste ich nicht, das wusste ich mir tatsächlich mal merken,
tatsächlich, ok das ist cool, das wusste ich nicht, da kann man ja die iTracks zum
ersten Mal ordentlich ansteuern, das wusste ich mir merken, das ist ja mal Chat wieder
was gelernt, ja, ja das ist wirklich cool, ich habe das bisher immer ausgelesen über
SSH, SSH eingeloggt beim iTrack und dann irgendwelche komischen SSH Befehle ausgeführt, schon mal
so eine Netzwerk-Virtualisierung gemacht, ja aber nicht wirklich so jetzt, dass ich
mich damit wahnsinnig auseinander gesetzt habe, ich habe mal schon virtuelle Switches installiert
beziehungsweise ich habe sogar mal docker auf einer MikroTik Kiste laufen, äh nicht docker,
Linux Container auf einer docker, äh auf einer MikroTik Kiste laufen lassen und wir haben
auch mal glaube ich auf irgendeinem Cisco Core Switch bei uns, da habe ich nur zugeguckt
bei der, also da nee da kann ich nichts zu hinschreiben, ja haben wir schon drin stehen
außer Chef, von Chef habe ich nicht viel Plan, das ist jetzt auch nicht so als wäre ich
da der krasse Checker, das haben wir schon drin stehen, aber wenn die mich danach fragen
muss ich sagen, ja ich habe damit schon was gemacht, ich kann damit auch was deployen,
ich weiß so prinzipiell, prinzipiell ja was man da so drauf gucken muss, aber der große
Kubernetes Checker bin ich nicht, also jetzt nicht so als könnte ich da irgendwie ein
Cluster selbst installieren und dass es dann auch irgendwie über mehrere Knoten gescheit
läuft, also da habe ich zu wenig Plan von, haben wir schon drin stehen, Crossplane habe
ich nicht drin stehen, genauso wenig wie biceps von ähm von Azure, weil habe ich auch zu
wenig mitgemacht bisher, Software Storage habe ich auch kein Plan, MQTD habe ich tatsächlich
ja, ich würde sagen das geht doch hier alles schon mal ganz gut klar, cools, nur mit dem
Unterschied dass ich von den Sachen die ich da reingeschrieben habe auch insofern Ahnung
habe, dass ich entweder gleich was damit machen könnte oder eben nach kurzer Zeit nochmal
angucken was machen könnte, ich habe mit allen Sachen die da drinstehen schon mal was
gemacht und zwar mehr als nur ein Finger krumm also, ich habe da aber, ich habe von Datenbanken
wenig Ahnung, deswegen, ich habe Poresquare als Full-Text-Dutch bisschen gemacht, ich
habe relativ viel SQLite, allein schon durch das ganze Programmierzeug hier gemacht, Cassandra
habe ich gar keine Ahnung, Leute wir haben doch letztens so einen komischen Kurs, erinnert
es, ist jetzt so ein Witz ne, ich will das nicht reinschreiben, wir haben doch letztens
so einen komischen Kurs gemacht von irgendeinem Bundesministerium, da gab es doch irgendwie
so einen Kurs, ich meine nicht diesen Arbeitsamt-Test, schon irgendwie ein halbes Jahr her, da hat
man so einen komischen Test gemacht, es war sowas wie der Internetführerschein, ich habe
schon wieder vergessen was das war, schreibe auch noch eine Projektliste, beschreib mir
welche, Park Alter, das ist mir aber zu anstrengend, da muss ich mir jetzt echt Gedanken machen,
da müsste ich dann schreiben wie ich den Fiat Champ programmiert habe, ja wir haben das
on stream gemacht, irgendwo hat man Archive, bestes Fiat Archive, wieder einfach mal Live
Overflow, warum ist der hier in dem aktuellen Stream drinnen, achso weil wir das live geguckt
haben, ähm, Zwelt Auto Complete und Postgres Text Search, Jupp da ist es guck, Jason Jaml
haben wir schon drinnen, Projektliste, boah ey das ist dann aber ganz schön anstrengend,
ich muss, ich muss wie gesagt den Lebenslauf noch fertig machen, ich habe das schon geschrieben
zum größten Teil, ich muss noch gucken, dass das Datum stimmt und sowas da drin steht,
mit welchen Mail Providern hast du denn Gabe, was, Gmail, Webmail, Yahoo, mehr oder weniger
keine Ahnung, ja Gmail, GMX aber wen jucken das, bitte schön, was die interessieren würde
ist eher sowas wie, ähm, ob ich Ahnung von Postfix oder Q-Mail oder Exim oder was es
da nicht alles gibt habe, Dofkort, ja genau, NPM, ja das ist tatsächlich keine schlechte
Idee, MS-Build, war komplett andere Scheiß, ich schreibe einfach dabei, ich schreibe einfach
dabei, Sprachen, da schon reingeschaut, das ist eigener, das ist mein Stil, Leute, das
ist, hier ist nichts Obvious, ich habe schon Dinger gelesen, teilweise im Chat, da kann
ich nicht wissen, ob einer G-Baded oder nicht, aha, aha, ich glaube, das ist verbuggt vom
Serious Max an der Stelle, weil man nicht über die Startseite geht, der müsste noch
ein Fallback in seine Svelte-Kit-Anwendung einbauen, Tools, ähm, ich habe noch eine
Idee, Moment, Tools, Azure CLI, Unit-Tests, mit sowas gebe ich mich erst gar nicht ab,
wir programmieren einfach fehlerfrei und dementsprechend brauchen wir auch keine Tests
und wenn man keine Tests braucht und einen Fehlerfall programmiert hat, braucht man auch
keine Dokumentation und auch keine Kommentare, ganz einfach, was das für Zeit spart alles,
einfach keine Fehler machen beim Programmieren, ist doch ganz einfach, hast du vor das Markdown
Dokument, ja, ich werde das wahrscheinlich als PDF, PDF machen, tatsächlich habe ich
von den, ähm, hält man das so, Browser, Browser-Steuerung, ja, ja leider und ich weiß
nicht woran es liegt, ich weiß nicht, ich weiß nicht woran es liegt, es ist irgendwie
kaputt, es ist irgendwie kaputt, ja das knackt es manchmal, wartet mal, ich guck mal hier
oben, ich guck mal kurz hier oben dran, ob ich, wenn ich das bewege, ob das was hilft,
ob das ein Sack, Kacke, warte mal, warum bewegt sich hier nichts, aha, so, exellent, ja, alle
wieder geknackt, meint ihr, meint ihr das ist der Stecker, an dem ich gerade rumgewackelt
war, erwähnt bloß den Stream nicht, warum, also mach ich nicht, aber warum, also ich werde
nicht, nichts von YouTube und sonst wie, ich werde vielleicht, ja bin ich mir noch unschlüssig,
ich werde wahrscheinlich reinschreiben, in den Lebenslauf ab 2012, dass ich, wie nennt
man das eigentlich, neben beruflich Selbststände, nee das ergibt keinen Sinn, wie schreibt
man das, dass ich seit 2012 eine eigene Firma hab und damit Zeugs mache, wie, wie, ja, frei
beruflicher Medien, alter Sixheader, ey, das muss ich mir, das muss ich mir aufschreiben,
da hätt ich nie drauf, nie dran gedacht, ja, Webvideoproduzent, ja, frei beruflicher
Medien, ja, nee, nein, das schreibe ich so nicht, ok, ich glaube das reicht jetzt, Leute,
Das reicht jetzt Leute, ich glaube das ist genug, das ist glaube ich wirklich genug.
Sieht sich doch kein Mensch alles durch.
Und hier machen wir die Rakete raus.
Muss eh noch kürzen, nee das knalle ich denen einfach so hin.
Kann jemand ein gachi emote reinschreiben, gachi bass kannst du reinschreiben zum Beispiel.
Ja gachi hyper gachi.
Überqualifiziert ist ein bescheuerter Begriff, damit ist eigentlich gemeint, den kannst
nicht gebrauchen, das ist sowas wie übervorteilt, das ist auch so eine bescheuerte Formulierung.
Gut ich glaube das reicht jetzt, chat wenn euch noch was einfällt schreibt das ruhig
in den Chat, ansonsten wollen wir mal gucken ob es irgendwelche interessanten Videos gibt.
Also wir hätten hier zu bieten, was ist denn das, war ja gut wo ich es aufgemacht habe,
wir hätten noch dings zu bieten hier, level, nicht level keck, fire ship neues video.
Hast du raspberry pi krams reingekriegt, du hast recht habe ich nicht, könnte man bei
iot reinschreiben aber einfach nur weil es sich, warum nicht, dns active directory ldap
habe ich keine ahnung von, kann dns aber benutzen, aber von active directory ldap habe ich wirklich
keinen plan.
Was der youtube editor für den video, wortkanal, was meinste, muss da wieder zeug rausgeschnitten
werden oder was, ich will das gar nicht reinschreiben da kommt noch einer auf die idee, ich soll
später active directory machen, guck mal mein eigenes video wird empfohlen, das muss
ich kurz mal starten und muten im tap, was ist hier los, mit dem firefox kann man das
im tap muten, video starten, view time, youtube, was wollt ihr von mir, geht mal weg, hallo
leute hier ist der max und jetzt muten, exellent, view time, chefs habe ich reingeschrieben
allerdings weder solstack noch chef weil ich davon zu wenig plan habe, die wahrheit wurde
revealed leute, nur bei level cap
was ist das, ey das ist echt gut gemacht, ich meine die beleuchtung stimmt nicht so
ganz aber das ist wirklich gut gemacht
das ist gut, das hat er wirklich gut gemacht
wie lange hat er daran gerendert, ey welche spannenden videos da drin, must have services
auf dem heim server, ok nix was ich wahrscheinlich brauche, ja die videos werden mir empfohlen
aber das meiste ist mir zu hyper aktiv, also wirklich spannend, das ist ja heute noch dabei
oder, blazingly fast, ja ja haben wir alles schon drin stehen, haben wir alles schon drin
stehen, battlewolf haben wir alles schon drin stehen, ok was, physics sagt, hey max, hab
es vorhin schon kurz geschrieben aber war dann kurz weg, mein internet geht nicht aber
das ist schlecht, die fritzbox zeigt trotzdem an, dass telecom gesynced ist und ipv4 verbunden
ist, ja gut das kann ja schon sein, im funktionstesterbox hängt er trotzdem bei internetverbindung
dns aber habe ich schon getestet, hast du vielleicht eine idee, kriegst du eine ip,
also klappt die dsl einfach, kriegst du eine ip, kann ja durchaus sein, dass du eine ip
kriegst und es danach nicht weiter geht, danach die telecom gerade irgendwelche probleme,
das kann ja auch sein, also ich würde einfach mal gucken ob die einwahl klappt, nee ping
auf dns aber geht nicht würde ich mal so sagen oder, so interpretiere ich das, ping auf
dns geht nicht, traceroute wird ihm wahrscheinlich, ja doch in dem fall könnte vielleicht traceroute
sogar wirklich ein bisschen was bringen, normalerweise bringt traceroute meistens nichts aber doch
in dem fall könnte es vielleicht doch, ja doch in dem fall könnte traceroute wahrscheinlich
doch was bringen aber solange er keine public ip kriegt bzw. überhaupt keine ip kriegt
ob bei seiner fritzbox dann weiß mir ja schon was sache ist, jo nice, ich weiß nicht ob
das was taugt, taugts was, ich hab das nicht, ich hab ja wie gesagt einen dreamscreen, leute
ich stehe grad vor der wahl, was soll ich mir, ok fangen wir erstmal an, wenn ich ende
des jahres tatsächlich kündigen sollte, dann muss ich ja mein firmenhandy zurückgeben
und bei der gelegenheit wollte ich auch mir eh jetzt schonmal ein neues handy kaufen,
ein eigenes neues handy, weil ich muss ja auch die ganze zwei faktor authentifizierungs
services die ich über die firmenhandy nummer laufen hab umstellen, so ich bin grad am überlegen
was ich für ein handy kaufen soll, ich hatte die letzten jahre über eigentlich nur iphones
aus dem grund, weil ich es nicht bezahlen musste, das heißt die grundsätzliche frage
ist android oder apple aber ganz ehrlich, ich tendiere eigentlich weiterhin zum apple,
ich sehe auch für mich gerade keinen irgendwie richtigen grund warum ich irgendwie umsteigen
sollte und mich an was neues gewöhnen muss, der einzige richtige vorteil von android
bei mir wäre jetzt, dass ich sagen könnte ja, ich könnte natürlich da deutlich mehr
automatisierung und spielereien machen, ihr wisst ja sowas mach ich gerne, ios kann sich
ja kaum was machen in der richtung, aber ansonsten, wahrscheinlich wirds ein iphone, dann ist
halt die frage welches iphone, ich tendiere aktuell zu einem 14 pro oder einem 13 pro
aber 13 pro gibts nicht mehr zu kaufen, ansonsten würde ich ansonsten, weil ich finde die sache
mit 120 hertz ganz cool und diese komische dynamic island geschichte oder so, brauche
ich noch beim besten will nicht, aber ok, was kostet denn das aktuell, apple willst aber
wissen ey, alter was sind denn das für smartphone preise man, dafür hast du, für das hast du
letztes jahr noch high end grafikkarten gekriegt, heut kostet nicht high end grafikkarten das
doppelte und das iphone ist doppelt so teuer wie davor, schau wirklich mal rein ok, china
chinesen kram, haben die sich gedacht, jetzt wo apple vorne diese komischen kameras drauf
hat, jetzt machen wir das auch oder wie, dabei war das bei apple schon ne ziemlich beschissene
idee, dass das ding jetzt ohne hülle nicht mehr flach auf dem tisch liegt, hypercharge
ich kauf mir nix von ebay klein anzeigen, mal ganz davon abgesehen ebay klein anzeigen
hat mich ja sogar gebannt, ich kann doch nicht mal was drauf kaufen, sie haben mich gebannt
obwohl ich nicht mal einen account hatte, ist auch geil oder, can't wait, tja, na gut, warum
haben die hier eigentlich so nen dickshot gemacht, von dem typ, dass man hier so richtig schön
den schritt gefilmt hat, warum, so und das ist schon ganz schön teuer, 13 pro, ah das
ist, wow, general überholt und dann fast so teuer wie das 14er, nee das ist nix oder,
das ist doch nix, ach guck mal ist doch neu, nee das sind warehouse deals, ach das sind
auch warehouse deals, das ist used, das ist auch used, aha, ok, keine ahnung, kauf mir
den iphone 13, bei aliexpress jetzt, wimpern, verlängerung, zubehör, alles klar dann haben
die bestimmt auch iphone 13 pro, easy, kein case, auch nicht iphone, alter das kostet
in china einfach 2000 euro, aber immerhin 5 euro rabatt, möb, dankeschön für den sub,
hattet statt zu gucken, also ich hab wieder hier die hälfte übersehen, möb, danke
für den sub, seriousmax auch, an dich danke, eclipse, nee, eclipsi oder so, ähnlich, ich
hoffe ich spreche das richtig aus, dankeschön für den sub, gestern gestern gut, da haben
gar nicht so viel übersehen, ich wusste nicht ob ihr es wisst, ja aber ich erwähne
das mal, weil ich mache zu wenig sellout, falls ihr amazon prime habt und euch das noch
nicht klar ist, wusste ihr dass ihr mit amazon prime einen streamer eurer wahl einmal im monat
kostenlos mit einem prime sub unterstützen könnt, nicht dass der noch verfällt, das
wollen wir ja nicht, any primers, genau, any primers, wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich
hol ich mir wirklich wieder ein iphone, nice leute, hacky, dankeschön für den sub, 3
10 monat am start, juicybit zum ersten mal, pog, dankeschön, nice, pausierungschamp,
wollen wir noch das fireship video gucken, Leute, devil's argent 11 und der rezo boy
auch am start, schön dass ihr da seid, danke für den sub, hi iq subscription, chat iq steigt
wieder ins unermessliche, wisst ihr jeder sub einmal iq++ für den chat, das scam train
fasst schon auf level 2, hast du geguckt ob du public ip kriegst, das komische ist dass
er mir in der box aber trotzdem ein externer ip anzeigt, kannst du die externe ip pingen,
klingt jetzt doof, müsste gehen weil es lokal auf der fritzbox ist, aber man weiß ja nie
ob es auch wirklich noch drauf ist, überall auf dem interface, oder dass es nur das mist
anzeigt, wobei ich weiß nicht, blockt das nicht die fritzbox, egal von wo das kommt
wenn man die externe ip pingt, zeigt nur die fritzbox auch, na gut der nächste, deswegen
ist halt race route kacke, der nächste router könnte durchaus einfach lcmp zeug blocken,
aber ist egal, ich vermute mal es liegt an der telekom, hast du irgendwas gemacht in
letzter zeit mit der fritzbox, wahrscheinlich nicht, die ging gestern und heute ist die kaputt
oder, das sieht mir sehr nach telekom probleme aus ehrlich gesagt, wenn die einwahl geht
und du ne public ip kriegst, so komm wir gucken jetzt noch, ping auf die ex, also ich würde
fast vermuten es liegt davor, die einwahl geht und es geht ab quasi, ab dem ersten hopp
von der telekom nicht richtig weiter, vielleicht oder auch ab dem zweiten, also man weiß es
ja nicht genau, also ich vermute das liegt an der telekom, du könntest mal gucken, obbei
ne bringt ja nichts, hätten wir bei race route wahrscheinlich schon gesehen, ich denke es
liegt an der telekom, ja das wird an der telekom liegen, die haben probleme wahrscheinlich,
wahrscheinlich ist dann dein erster provider hopp router abgekackt oder was auch immer
oder irgendwas lokal, wandermaus, danke schon für den sub, also ich würde mich bei der
telekom wenden, ich glaube nicht das es an dir liegt, ok wollen wir noch das fireship
video gucken, aber noch fireship, how to improve react performance, wo kostüm, was könnte
ich denn, was könnte ich denn gut, als was könnte ich mich denn gut verkleiden, verkleiden,
ist pepo fat gruselig genug, da ziehe ich mir einfach ein grünes t-shirt, blaues t-shirt
an, doch wir sind fertig patrick, wir sind fertig, wie wäre es wenn ich als guter stehe,
da müsste ich mich aber ganz schön roleplayen für oder, bist du überhaupt noch pepo fat
genug, naja ich habe mein ziel mit unter 90 bis ende des jahres noch nicht erreicht,
ich meine ich habe angefangen bei 108,5 und ich bin jetzt relativ lange schon so bei 92
oder 91,8 oder 92,2, das schwankt, ok wir gucken jetzt noch mal das fireship video, was
war denn, ok fireship erzähl uns was, immer tons of money ist nie verkehrt, hast du schon
mal, wie es, das ist dieser, ja ich habe sogar, ob das habe ich so, nee habe ich nicht, habe
ich nicht, weil die microsoft c++ extensions nur fürs offizielle wishlist studio code funktionieren,
also ich habe das schon probiert ja aber ich verwende es nicht, weil das c++ plugin irgendwelche
proprietären microsoft shit enthält, das nur mit dem offiziellen wishlist studio code
geht, loop guard, ach nee, nee, loot, loot guard, eigentlich schon für den zapp, iacu
subscription, gehen wir mal weiter, ich habe so keinen plan vom react ökosystem, es rauscht
so, gehen wir mal weiter, is that genius, ok, here to feel inspired by features bride and
remix like nest that is about to hear told
tonight about you, you feel inspired by those features
and elsewhere, interesting though is that less than a year ago, shopify came out with
mit ihrem eigenen React-Framework, Hydrogen.
So wie in Next 13,
Hydrogen nutzt React-Server-Komponenten,
das ist die offizielle Lösung des React-Teames
für Server-Side-Rendering.
Wie viele...
Ich frage mal gar nicht,
wie viele JavaScript-Frameworks
gibt es eigentlich, weil das
nähert sich der Unendlichkeit.
Aber allein schon im ganzen
React-Ökosystem,
wie viele gibt's da mittlerweile eigentlich?
Da blickt doch keiner mehr durch.
Next.js, 13 soll ja auch 700 mal
schneller sein als Webpack.
Ja, nicht Next.js 13, oder?
Sondern Mono-Build
oder Mono-Pack, oder wie dieser
Kram hieß.
Shopee!
Endlich mal einer, der ein gutes Web-Framework
verwendet. Ruby on Rails ist
POG. Ich mein, ich würd's jetzt nicht mal
verwenden, aber ich mag Ruby on Rails.
GitLab ist Ruby on Rails, das weiß ich.
Chat sagt, er wird nie wieder...
äh, nicht Chat.
Extreme aus dem Chat sagt, er wird nie wieder
JavaScript anfassen, sondern nur noch WebAssembly.
Ja, das Problem ist, ganz ohne JavaScript
geht's halt trotzdem nicht, ne?
Wie willst du aus WebAssembly
beispielsweise irgendwelche Webseiten-Anpassungen
machen?
Way too dank, Leute.
Mikrofon knackt nicht mehr
als fuck ab. Was macht's denn jetzt schon
wieder?
Was ist denn jetzt?
Hat sich doch überhaupt nichts geändert, oder?
Ich hab ne Idee.
Ich schließ mal morgen
das Mikrofon
an das andere
Audio-Interface an.
Und dann gucken wir mal.
Müssen wir dann mal schauen, ob das...
Naja, werden wir dann mal schauen, ob das
gescheit funktioniert.
Ja.
Ja, werden wir dann mal schauen, ob das gescheit
funktioniert. Ich mein...
Sounds...
Ach, ich hab' das gar nicht mehr angeschlossen,
dull.
Hin und wieder Störgeräusche, okay.
Vielleicht, das ist aber auch
Einfach nur twitch heute abend weil ich habe doch normalerweise nie probleme
Vielleicht das ist aber auch einfach nur twitch heute abend weil ich habe doch
Hört sich auch nach nix an
Vielleicht muss ich mal meinen
Streaming game absteppen hier
Wackelkontakt, ja vielleicht
Ich könnte hier mal ein bisschen
ein bisschen dran wackeln oder so aber
Ja, ich habe keine Ahnung
Keine Ahnung
Müssen wir mal gucken also ich update gerade keine
Sinnvolle Erklärung für
Hast du schon mit roher Gewalt gesehen was soll ich denn wo soll ich draufhauen
Was in der Nähe ist so ok ich muss mir das jetzt mal kurz noch mal anschauen
Anschauen anhören ist denn ist das nicht in der Aufnahme gerade drinne ok ich muss mir das jetzt mal kurz
Also ich ich höre dann nichts
Ist das so bla bla bla bla test test bla bla bla bla bla bla bla test test
bla bla bla bla bla bla test test
Keine Ahnung gibt es ein neues Heartbleed
Bei dem ich höre da nichts war es sehr schön zu hören
Also ich könnte das mal als andere audio interface anschließen aber dann muss ich gucken wie ich einen Rechner kriege von da
Störgeräusche ok ok jetzt können wir hier
Ist das nicht in der Aufnahme gerade drinne ok ich muss mir das jetzt mal kurz nochmal
Da hatten wir es doch doch
Tatsächlich das hat ein bisschen aussetzer
Ist das irgendwie mein
Noisegate oder sowas rumspackt
Man weiß ja nie
Die Lautstärke richtig so test test test test test test den jetzt müsste eigentlich gehen
Keine Ahnung
Am ende noch mehr
Also ich ich höre da nichts
Was
Ich höre da nichts
Also ich höre da nichts
Also ich ich höre da nichts
Wow
Ok da ist irgendwo irgendwas kaputt bei mir
Und das liegt das liegt nicht an meinen Twitch Settings
Und das liegt auch nicht an meinen OBS Filtern ich meine da hat sich ja nichts getan seit gestern
Ich speicher mir das mal
Es muss ich ja es muss ja irgendwas sein ja vielleicht bin ich ein paar Mal zu viel übers Kabel gerollt oder so
Kein Plan
Kein Plan weil normalerweise gibt es ja keine Probleme
Da war es auch wieder ordentlich
Ich lasse mal kurz mitlaufen sagt sagt mir wenn es wieder gewesen ist
Dann gucke ich nämlich dann gucke ich nämlich hier mal in der Audacity Aufnahme ob das ob das damit was zu tun hat
Ja
Schauen wir mal ist natürlich ist natürlich jetzt blöd das
Wenn wir das jetzt irgendwie live live on stream debuggen müssen
Dabei haben wir eigentlich gar nicht mehr großartig wie gesagt ich weiß ja nicht was ich heute noch machen soll wir sind wir sind ja eigentlich fertig damit
Jetzt pass auf jetzt jetzt habe ich das hier laufen und jetzt kommt wahrscheinlich nichts
Das geht jetzt schon naja mal gucken es gibt eigentlich nichts mehr was wir machen können
Einzige was mir einfällt ich könnte man das audio interface tatsächlich mal raus
Döpseln und wieder rein stöpseln ob das was bringt
Ah
Also ich mein wenn es die Aufnahme jetzt hier nebenbei fixt was ja eigentlich nicht sein kann
Also am bewegen liegt es nicht leute ich ich wackele jetzt hier hin und her und es ist überhaupt gar kein Problem
Also ich bewege jetzt ja alles kabel und sonst wie das ist wahrscheinlich sogar
Einen Winners ding oder tatsächlich in den wackelkontakt irgendwas an anderer stelle
Also gute gute frage ich werde das audio interface mal rein raus machen und mal windows neu starten das hilft ja das wirkt ja das wirkt ja wunder oftmals windows neu starten
Im clip hast du dazu auch was im browser parallel gemacht okay jetzt reloaden wir einfach mal wir reloaden jetzt ganz wild irgendwie
Ob das damit was zu tun hat ich mein man weiß ja man weiß ja hier nie
Wait a minute wenn ich den browser reloade ich meine man weiß ja man weiß ja hier nie
Wait a minute wir reloaden jetzt ganz wild irgendwelche seiten ob das damit was zu tun hat
What the fuck
Wenn meine cpu was macht das ist irgendein windows shit oder
Das einzige was ich gemacht habe die letzten tage ist ich habe modern warfare installiert
Ist es der modern warfare anti cheat oder was
Kekkel
Aha
Safe
Aha safe
Klar habe ich mw2 beendet okay mal gucken ob wir das nachvollziehen können
Ich ich reload jetzt noch mal ganz die ganze zeit hier meinen browser
Irgendwelche sachen reloaden bis bis in cpu na gut ich mein cpu last können wir auch antarbeit ich leute
Cpu last können wir auch antarbeit ich generieren
Wobei dafür brauche ich noch nicht mal hier cpu last können wir antarbeit ich generieren echo
2 hoch 1 2 3 4 nach bc
Ach nee bc haben wir nicht
Wie erzeugt man denn auf windows last
Irgendjemand eine schlaue idee
War das ist das jetzt wieder beim windows beim beim wenn ich den browser reloade
Macht es dann wieder dinger
Anhören ist das
Oder jetzt nicht mehr
Es war wieder leicht
Ok ok ok ok ok
Und jetzt jetzt macht er richtig jetzt macht er richtig fett jetzt macht er richtig fett ich auch
Gerade und ein bisschen cpu last wenn die vm gestartet wird
Das juckt das juckt jetzt ja
Ja
interessant interessant ok
Waren wir mal waren wir mal cpu last
So jetzt haben wir cpu last
So, jetzt haben wir CPU-Last, guckt hier, ist es jetzt am abkacken, test, test, test,
test, test, test, nope, nix, also CPU-Last allein ist es schonmal nicht, ok, CPU-Last
alleine ist es nicht, so, weil wir haben jetzt, wir haben jetzt ganz schön die CPU-Last,
also mehr macht es der Browser, ist es Disk, ist es Disk IO, vielleicht, äh, irgendwas
aus den Ideen oder so, mal, wie viel Platz haben wir hier noch, ah, haben wir noch genug,
def zero, äh, oder machen wir so hier, keckel.bin, aber ich muss Disk IO auf C wahrscheinlich
machen, macht das irgendwas, ne, oder, alles gut, also ich mein jetzt ist der Rechner,
der Rechner ist jetzt ordentlich ausgelastet, ok, das interessiert den nicht, ok, ok, Disk
IO auf C müssen wir machen, Disk IO auf C, wie mach ich denn, wie macht man, wie macht
man Disk IO unter Windows, Dateien kopieren, oder, Dateien kopieren, haben wir hier irgendwas
größeres, was ich kopieren kann, details, ne, Desktop, size, viele kleine Dateien, viele
kleine Dateien, wo hab ich viele kleine Dateien, hier, komm, mal jetzt einfach mal nen Ordner,
der sich KekWaite nennt, ah, CPU-Auslastung lassen wir, macht das irgendwas, hat das irgendwelche
Auswirkungen gehabt, ok, KekWaite wird wieder gelöscht, Chrome, Chrome hat viele Files,
das können wir kopieren, Chrome, Chromium kopieren wir, ich glaub ich hab kein, ich
glaub ich hab kein Node Modules hier drauf, aber das, was, wait a minute, ist das vielleicht
das Problem, dass meine Festplatte voll ist, ne, die ist 18 Gigabyte, das reicht dafür
bloß nicht, na geil, ne, ne, 18, 18G müssen noch reichen, ich will meinen Rechner nicht
statten, hier sind viele kleine Files drin, ok, copy, da, excellent, beste, so wie schaut
es jetzt aus, so wie schaut es jetzt aus, juckt es überhaupt nicht, Leute wisst ihr
was, ich glaub ich werd mal neu starten und wir gucken ob das morgen immer noch da ist,
das ist dem hier egal, es ist aber schon ganz schön langsam, obwohl es ne SSD, also ich
mein das ist ne NVMe SSD, der sollte auch kleine Dateien ein bisschen schneller kopieren,
obbei es ist immer, es ist Windows Zeug, wer weiß, wer weiß, ey Leute ich sag euch ohne
Scheiß, das ist der Modern Warfare Anti-Cheat, ich hab das zum ersten mal gestartet nach
dem Stream am Sonntag, und da war doch noch nix oder, am Sonntag war noch nix, also ich
mein das ist ja irgendein Rootkit Anti-Cheat oder sowas, ja ich hab ja auch nicht im Browser
rumgeklickt, ah im Browser, im Browser rumklicken ist anscheinend gefährlich hier, guckt hier,
Browser rumklicken machts kaputt, Windows Update, neues Soundtreiber, Quatsch was,
was soll denn da passiert sein in der Zwischenzeit, ich hab da nix geupdatet, ich mach mal kurz
das Audio Interface rein und raus, man weiß ja, man weiß ja nicht, doch vielleicht was
ist, so jetzt, oh war das überhaupt das Audio Interface, Sekunde, was hab ich hier gerade
rein rausgezogen, ah das war gar nicht das Audio Interface, das ist das Audio Interface
hier, drin, ok, ja daran wirds nicht gelegen haben, also ok, keine Ahnung, ich weiß es
nicht, schauen wir mal, es ist zumindest, es ist zumindest schonmal hier in der Aufnahme
drin, was dafür spricht, es ist zumindest schonmal, das ist irgendwas Windows technisches
oder Aufnahme technisches ist, wer weiß, keine Ahnung, schauen wir mal wie es morgen
ist, ich werde, wenn es gar nichts hilft, ich werde einfach Modern Warfare 2 wieder
deinstallieren, fertig, Leute wir sehen uns, ich geh jetzt auf, weiß eh nicht was ich heute
noch machen soll, wir haben ja das geschafft, was wir schaffen wollten, morgen nix, das
Stream mal gucken, vielleicht, ja, Leute wir sehen uns bis denn, machts gut, CU.